dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here this
video is not about a paper but about the
video series itself I don't do this
often
but for the sake of transparency I
wanted to make sure to tell you about
this we have recently hit a hundred and
seventy five thousand subscribers on the
channel
I find this number almost unfathomable
and please know that this became a
possibility only because of you so I
would like to let you know how grateful
I am for your support here on YouTube
and patreon as most of you know I still
work as a full time researcher at the
Technical University of Vienna and I get
the question why not go full time on two
minute papers from you fellow scholars
increasingly often the answer is that
over time I would love to but our
current financial situation does not
allow it let me explain that first I
tried to run the channel solely on
YouTube ads which led to a rude
awakening most people myself included
are very surprised when they hear that
the rates had become so low that around
the first 1 million viewer mark the
series earned less than a dollar a day
then we introduced patreon and with your
support we are now able to buy proper
equipment to make better videos for you
I can without hesitation say that you
are the reason this channel can exist
everything is better this way now we
have two independent revenue sources
patreon being the most important however
whenever YouTube or patreon monetization
issues arise you see many other channels
disappearing into the ether I am
terrified of this and I want to do
everything I possibly can to make sure
that this does not happen to us and we
can keep running the series for a long
long time however if anything happens to
any of these revenue streams
simply put we are toast even though it
would be a dream come true
because of this it would be
irresponsible to go full-time on the
papers to remedy this we have been
thinking about introducing a third
revenue stream with sponsorships for a
small amount of videos each month the
majority 75% of the videos would remain
patreon supported
and the remaining 25% would be sponsored
just enough to enable me and my wife to
do this full-time in the future there
would be no other changes to the videos
patreon supporters get all of them in
early access and as before I choose the
papers too with this if something
happens to any of the revenue streams we
would be able to keep the series afloat
without any delays I would also have
more time to every now and then fly out
and inform key political decision makers
on the state of AI so they can make
better decisions for us everything else
would remain the same the videos would
arrive more often in time and the dream
could perhaps come true I think
transparency is of utmost importance and
wanted to make sure to inform you before
any change happens I hope you are ok
with this and if you are a company and
you are interested in sponsoring the
series let's talk as always thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time